Let's talk about the generate method,
and like I said, we're going to
be given some training leg, examples and
we want to predict the labels, okay?
I need a little bit of an invitation
because we're going to do a trivial
amount of math.
This little notation,
4 to 9 means an object is really
a four but I call it a 9.
We're going to talk about the costs or
the loss,
you're going to see L for
loss, you know,
what's the, the cost to me of
calling a 4 a 9 or calling a 9 a 4?
All right?
And one of the things we're going to
assume for the rest of today, and
it's really not a big deal,
you can factor we're going to assume the
cost of calling an X an X is zero, okay?
So nobody gets upset if I call
a spade a spade, so to speak.
So, let's consider the two class
binary classification problem.
Remember we just had 4s and 9s.
So we have two kinds of losses,
all right?
So that's what this L means.
An L of 4 9 is the loss of
classifying a 4 as a 9.
And conversely, L of 9 to 4 is
the loss of classifying a 9 as a 4.
Okay?
Pretty straightforward.
Risk is your expected cost, okay?
So, if I've got a particular strategy,
S, classifier strategy S.
We want to talk about what's
the expected loss, all right?
And for our 4 and 9 example,
the risk of our strategy
is, what's the probability
that I'll call a 4 a 9.
And how often is that going to happen?
Okay.
Using this particular strategy, and
I multiply that by whatever the loss is,
the cost of calling a 4 9,
and what's the probability
of calling a 9 a 4 and
what's the loss when I call a 9 or 4?
All right?
And that's the risk because
the probability is, you know,
15% of the time that I'm running
this thing, 15% of the times,
I'm going to 4 is going to come up and
I'm going to call it a 9.
Okay, that's what probability
of calling a 4 9 means.
So this total quantity,
that's what's referred to as your risk.
And remember what we want to do is we
want to minimize the expected risk.